welcome to Saturday morning success the
show that shares with you the secrets of
success in life relationships and in
business it must be saturday morning
that's why you guys are all here we're
so glad to have you here every Saturday
morning for the saturday morning success
television talk show and Naomi I mean
Jennifer how are you doing call me I
know I saw her picture come up on the
video I was confused I was like wait a
minute she took vacation and I don't
know that she's coming back we're gonna
have to put your picture up you better
be nice so I'm gonna go on vacation with
her oh my gosh oh ok i will be nice then
so hey are you happy about today i'm
more than happy I'm excited good super
excited we have a great guest today Miss
Mary similar how you die are you guys
okay it's so glad to be out here with
you oh man let me tell you a little bit
about Mary Mary is incredible mary has
been a doctor and a nurse and mba and
and is a director of films and all this
incredible stuff producer no i said
director yeah sorry i know you want to
be the director though right right okay
okay so producer of films and incredible
amounts of success in your life and
you've also been over some challenges
that right absolutely so we're going to
talk about those things and what we want
to do is find out we want to start out
with a little bit about what you're
doing now with some films but then let's
go right into what the challenges are
that you've been through in your life
okay and then we'll move forward with
that how you got over those things okay
I came out to California in 2010
expecting to do nothing I came out from
one of the challenges and we'll talk
about that a little bit later but I ran
into a by accident one of my conferences
I ran into a young director from Austria
with your heart no
we met I said later i should say that's
good director from austria vienna
austria named alexander vesely and he
was doing interviews at the conference
that i was attending and i thought he
was some ordinary kid with a camera
running around but we just buddied up
and became friends on a week during the
conference at the end of the conference
i went to the hotel coffee shop to have
dinner that night after all the staff
had gone home it's a very busy week so I
just want to chill out stay over 190 ya
boy the train i would go to the sky the
next day do all that stuff and he came
in and sat down and said can I have
dinner with you I said sure so we're
sitting there and suddenly all these
world famous psychiatrist started coming
over to the table Oh Alice I'm so
honored to meet you Oh Alice when you
get back to Austria please give you your
like this guy I'm like candid camera or
something wait a minute I'm missing so
glad he just wanted a date right no it
worked at least 25 years younger than me
but the girls were after him believing
he's a chick magnet so um it was it was
really the strangest thing it was almost
like being in the twilight zone so after
the last one left i said okay i may be
stupid but I'm not that stupid who are
you really and he laughed he said I'm
nobody he said they just want
information about my grandfather I said
okay I'll bite who's your grandfather he
said Victor Franko I said oh shut up I
wasn't there in to Elvis well for those
of you who may not be aware dr. Victor
Frankel's probably one of the best known
figures in the world his long selling
bestseller man's search for meaning had
sold over 16 million copies worldwide
and well he's probably best known for
that book although he created 33 other
books in his lifetime right and for
being a very famous outspoken Holocaust
survivor I'm reading the book right now
yeah it's terrific yeah it's um I read
the book the first time in
67 66 somewhere in that neighborhood my
first psychology course it was required
reading when I was in college and then
fast forward to working and one of my
other careers which is a media company
that I own an American Psychiatric
Association is one of my clients and so
I was attending their conference and he
was a keynote speaker there and speaking
in front of 10,000 people and you know
he got the Oscar Pfister award from that
group for the greatest thinker of the
20th century's so fast forward to 2008's
happened to move 3,000 miles away from
anything I knew run into his grandson in
a coffee shop in San Diego it's created
20 don't like zoning yeah so we talked
more than and not so well what are you
doing now and he said well I'm actually
going to do a archive project for the
victor frankl Institute in Vienna oh wow
he is the media archive director for the
Institute and I said I whites are going
to be about it was really about my
grandfather's work and I want to
interview all the people who he knew
personally want me was alive and get
their perspective on him before some of
them are really getting up there in
years and said before they're gone I
want to have their perspective right so
that we can keep that in the Institute
and I said now you've got to make this
story bigger than that right i viktor
frankl story needs to go to the world ya
know not to an archive drawer yeah so I
said wow you're gonna need to us
producer then I'm your girl and our sort
of half kidding because I didn't know
anything about producing film right I
have been producing conferences and see
these DVD roms webcasting all that kind
of thing well why not go all the way 30
years samisen well yeah world you know I
can say it but then you gotta produce
can I am acutely was it uh Richard
Branson is the one who always says jump
off the cliff and then figure it out on
the way down price well that's exactly
what I did with uh with this yeah so um
we sort of joked about it then but when
he got back to Austrian I guess he
started thinking about it and then the
next year in 2009 we met again at the
same conference that we got serious
about it but
he had 41 minutes of the film ready to
show that audience because it was a
group of psychiatrists and psychologists
and I watched it and I was just blown
away about the quality of the work and I
said okay we have to take this to the
world so we said about forming a company
we are we incorporate our business
called noetic films in 2010 I like that
name and it started right away and and
to get to this point I mean you've had
all kinds of great successes in your
life but let's talk about you out there
might be watching and you're thinking I
was never going to produce a film I'm
never going to be anything I'm going
through challenges you might have lost a
loved one you might be dealing with
cancer yourself or something right but
tell let's go deep for a minute here and
and talk about some of the challenges
that you've gone through it and then
we'll move from there well I had a
really great childhood and you know not
one of those that you know had had a
story to tell from childhood I had a
really great childhood I was lucky
enough to have a great family and my
father was a brilliant guy and I learned
so much from him I went through a great
childhood college years and into my 30s
and I would have said the 80s were
probably my most productive business
years because at that point may I start
again started my media company we just
happened this is another happenstance
story I pulled into and moved to
Washington DC from North Carolina and I
was looking for a house and I pulled it
to the sort of cult a sec called tobacco
quay tobacco cajon and I thought well at
least it's some semblance of home with
it tobacco store because I came from a
place with his lots of tobacco farms
right and I got bought a townhouse there
and then within 60 days the other Nancy
from the White House Nancy rentals moved
next door to me she had been Governor
Reagan's private secretary for three
years in California and came with ebony
started running for office in 79
well she said to me we're going to need
a media company could follow us around
into executive level recordings is your
company interested I said absolutely
yeah well finest up yeah so it took a
year off from all of our other work and
worked on the Reagan campaign the first
one for a whole year and did nothing but
that and then later on I got a contract
with the RNC to continue that work and
continued it up until I moved out here
in July of 2008 Wow august 2008 Wow but
tell us about some of the challenges
that you've been through in your life
okay well let's start with what I call
my own personal reign of terror okay I
like that this weird the flames own
heard the flames up my life was great i
met after doing all this work and the
company was going super um I met my um
my husband I was 35 when I met my
husband I thought I was never going to
get married and it Claire died wasn't
but one day I got on an airplane and I
sat down next to my mr. Darcy my Rhett
Butler all rolled into one and I got off
the plane that day and I called my best
friend and followed I said I met the man
today I'm gonna marry you knew that day
yeah that day Wow and she said well I've
heard that before I don't know this is
serious well it turned out it did happen
but not until two years later me the
long story short but anyway I thought we
had a great marriage everything was
going great up until I lost I started
with death and dying i call it the death
and dying dying around the kitchen table
mm-hmm first there was my grandmother
who got sick and died then there was my
father who got cancer got sick and died
and I was very close with my dad's yeah
the same situation I took a very big
part of my heart um well I always say it
made holes in my heart it starts like
paying bodies build up one at a time
after whenever the other I'm sure
they're not happy with me hitting the
microphones
but anyway so I was the caretaker for
all these people and that's not I like
the other side of the table better where
you're the health care giver not a
health care receiver right but anyway it
was my grandmother so I lost my father
and when I lost my father it really sent
me into a depression I I sort of
wouldn't go out the house for a couple
of years well i scaled back everything
and my husband was always there to help
and then i started slowly but sure he
going back to work and I always have
experienced something with each death
called complicated grief is what the
psychiatrist call it where you don't
really get over it before you get to the
next one and then my mother got sick and
died and I had to help take care of her
at the very end and deal with all that
loss then my best friend from college my
college roommate died and then but all
day all still I had my husband Don was
with me my rock right um and then he was
diagnosed with stage four cancer yeah
and when I saw the x-rays I come from a
healthcare background originally and she
said I knew where this situation was
going to go because he had he was a
voice-over artist in an actor in New
York and he had been experienced
experiencing symptoms of what we call
paroxysmal hoarseness where the
hoarseness would not stay it would come
and go right and when he would be doing
voiceover work in New York they would
have oftentimes have to stop the cameras
and start over because of that and so we
started searching for that problem two
years before was actually diagnosed and
he had a young Carson I'm up under the
left vocal cord so it was hiding and
just insidious I mean it off to does
this so it five otolaryngologists and
five states later oh my gosh finally got
a diagnosis at University Miami
unfortunately by that time the tumor had
wicked it's a google her head into
various organs of the body and he had
seating in the liver and seating in the
bones and sitting in the lungs and
seating everywhere well I never and
people can make their own individual
judgments about this I never told him
that how dire that situation looked from
a medical point of view because i don't
i don't think lo hooks are any good for
anybody right now so we went about
finding the best treatments and for the
next five years we went to every major
catastrophe you can imagine that's why
we call it dying around the kitchen
table now imagine this if you're an
actor and a singer and a voice of a guy
what's the worst thing that can happen
you they take out your voice true very
true he had to have a laryngectomy he
had to learn to use an artificial voice
it was just every it seemed like every
week it was a different part of his
dignity they was lost and until finally
he lost the battle all together and I I
was I just was devastated but my best
friend who had been my best friend for
30 years paula was there Apollo helped
me really get through it again I took to
my bed it seemed like something i always
do i retreat to my house i call it being
like a wounded animal you know you sort
of curl up and you don't want to go
anywhere do anything right so I stayed
home and really just tried to heal and
then I'm gonna this is the next part of
the story is a little bit long so let's
talk about that maybe when we come back
yeah we're a break in a minute and and
we want to talk about the real impact of
all the tough things that you went
through you through a lot yeah bounce
back exactly and you lost it you lost
some other folks too after your that's
why I say the next part yeah yeps don't
want to get into that and then uh as
some of you out there may already know
you know that those are tough things to
deal with especially when they're
happening like a domino yeah then you
got to get down of it and you've come
out of it and become a producer of
movies and all kinds of stuff so we want
to hear some of your secrets on how you
did that okay so when we come back we're
going to spend more time with Mary Simba
Luca and learn more about the challenges
that she's gone through tremendous
challenges and how she's gotten out of
them so we'll be back right after these
short messages from our sponsors
hey welcome back boy we are really
learning about some of the challenges
we're just barely getting into some of
these challenges with Mary right and
what we want to hear is a little bit
more of the challenges that you went
through because we want to get to the
bottom before you went up and then maybe
share with us a little bit of what you
use to get out of these challenges okay
I'll be happy to well probably I told
you all about the complicated grief
process right we left off where your
your husband laughs gosh where my
husband died and then i would absolutely
refuse to go out of the house again for
three years and paul on my best friend
of 30 years was bringing food / she
would come over and visit with me and in
fact I we almost lost our friendship
during that time because at one point
she said now look this is this black
widow a giant black widow thing is
getting ridiculous you got to get out of
the house and I said the love of my life
is laying over there under a bed of
roses and if you ever say anything else
like that to me again our friendship is
over oh wow so that was the last she
heard of that but eventually I did start
to go back to church go out to dinner
once in a while started to crawl back
out and just when I thought it couldn't
get any worse she and her husband were
murdered in their own home oh my gosh Oh
at three o'clock in the morning one
morning I woke up and I looked at the
clock on my bed beside my bed and it
said 305 and I could hear Paula calling
me Mary help me help me Leon me Wow and
I had just talked to her at ten-thirty
the night before her husband was very
very ill and we thought he probably
would not make it until Christmas and
this was thanksgiving a time november
21st to be exact and i could hear her
calling me and I thought well
I'm not going to call her at this time
of night I had told her the next day I
would call her when I woke up right well
630 the phone rang and it was a Georgia
Bureau of Investigation person oh my
gosh and he said I'm afraid I have some
bad news for you are you alone and I
said yes I'm alone and he said well I'd
like for you to go get a neighbor to sit
with you while I talk to you oh my gosh
and I said just tell me whatever it is I
nothing you could say to me would be
worse than what I've already lived
through boy was I wrong about that right
yeah so he said I said it's it's about
Paula right don't tell me that Jack died
during the night that was her husband's
name and he said no ma'am he said I'm
afraid it's a little worse than that
they're both dead Wow they were killed
in the middle of the night in their home
and I just dropped the phone I just I
could feel it right now I just started
screaming I'm God you take everybody in
my life and you take her too how is this
possible now what has happened and then
I started acting really crazy I was
running around the house mopping the
kitchen floor doing the laundry I
couldn't figure out what to do and he's
grieving at the top of my lungs funding
my neighbors came over started pounding
on the door because they couldn't figure
out what was going on right there
screaming young right and I remember
Lorraine Sullivan my next-door neighbor
came in she said Mary what the heck is
wrong I said Paula's dad Paul said she
said oh no so they helped me kind of
pull myself together and I had to get on
the next flight go down to Georgia and
deal with her right you know and
everything but I I came back home and I
ended up in the psych ward wow I went
downhill downhill downhill downhill
downhill until I finally had a psychotic
break with reality I was in the hospital
nine days before I did even knew I was
here Wow yeah i just passed out on the
floor in my kitchen and my neighbor
found me and called 911 I was
Wow and I don't remember any of it not
even to this day going to the hospital
the first two weeks nothing I call that
God's anesthesia you know right so it
was a way of Late Night Ranger lady
membrane he like any been before so my
psychiatrist was really wonderful during
that whole time he said he can't like
you out of the hospital until we make a
decision of what you can do to have a
new life because the good news is you've
lost you you're going to live and the
bad news is you're going to live and the
reality is you've lost everybody you
love he said tell me if you close your
eyes and look around your house in your
mind's eye how many pictures are on your
wall of people who are alive none Wow
none everybody in my inner circle is
dead wow so he said okay let's do this
give me a favor read this book man's
search for meaning really it comes in
with it one morning I'm like I know all
about Franco I met him and I rent I
learned about him in the 60s i met him
in 87 man he said what just humor me
read it again so I put it on the side of
the bed and he said he'd do one more
thing for me so you're brilliant at
business he said he said I want you to
create for me a business plan for mary's
new life for tenure the CEO and you've
just been given this company to create a
new life for yourself now meanwhile I
have a chronic lung disease have
pulmonary fibrosis marching toward a
lung transplants I have my own health
challenges to deal with in the midst of
all this but I didn't care right you've
had that since I've had I've had was
started with asthma bronc riding
bronchitis built up over the years to
this pulmonary fibrosis and it's a
terminal lung condition my little doctor
keeps reminding me that i need to stop
work because i have a terminal illness
and I remind him it so does he count
life
I'm gonna get out of this alive but
anyway so I went home from house were
designed this business plan for my
psychiatrist and I showed it to him and
he said well that sounds like a good
idea and what I decided to do was take a
look at what do I really like i like
sunshine I like the ocean ok Jack media
yeah ok I what kind of temperature do i
want i want moderate capture year-round
check with what kind of business well my
company the media company can go
anywhere do anything doesn't matter
because our clients are all over the
world yeah so they didn't really matter
for work where I lived and so I I really
narrowed it down to I want to church
within one mile of me because that's
important to me I want a medical center
within five miles I want this that and I
finally found the spot I want to act a
55 community because I don't want to
deal with houses right yeah it's a lot
of work so i was just doing anything I
could to cocoon myself right into his
face was magic that was magical and I
found Ladera Ranch California six miles
up from Laguna be the nice nice to me
yeah yeah so God picks me up yeah brings
me here I say I was standing in a vat of
mud right and I'll and it in a vat of
sunshine hmm now I meet the Franco
connection I love is starting to pour
into me from all over the world because
of that that's amazing I like that yeah
yeah so I had all of these Franco
encounters over decades how funny right
and now and yet I've just this one
that's why i said to Ali's the day we
met shut up you are not Victor right
you're like no you're no good have it's
only 16 months ever came here but
there's a plan right and it's evident
when things like that Ryan Ryan so
what's in that in the book command
search for meaning or were there some
well dr. Franco dr. Franco taught that
regardless and this is how he man search
for meaning is actually in a can
his on the count of the his time in the
camps right and then which is only three
years out of his 90 plus years of life
on Earth by the longest three years ago
well he lost his whole family ray lost
his pregnant wife Tilly his mother his
father his brother Walter and his
sister-in-law right so he only had the
one sister left and she had gone to
Australia I think to living and that's
why she survived before the war right
but the rest of them were killed in the
camps and he barely survived himself but
when he came back to Vienna he he was
really depressed he was in exactly the
same spot i was when i landed here and
and decided to pour his heart out into a
manuscript because he was a great
thinker he was a great philosopher he
was a psychiatrist you know he was all
this and he always used his brain to
work himself out of things right and he
came up with three very specific ways
that we can find meaning in their life
and he taught us that regardless of the
circumstances we find ourselves in we
can always choose a meaningful life a
meaningful moment and we can choose our
thoughts Frankie's are actually Hannah
yeah so that's how the other thing i did
was i had my district idris he's so
wonderful who treated me said well why
don't you come up with some little
tricks you can use to get yourself out
when you feel yourself falling down into
the abyss frame so i developed some
tools i invented a little ceiling
sweeper and i will late in if I was
starting to feel myself starting to get
depressed I would lay down on the bed
made it a ritual mm-hmm I would bring
the little sweeper down and when he's
what I call the ants the automatic
negative thoughts I'm into my brain the
sweeper would sweet my brain clean of
them and then I would let this sweeper
go back up and then I was done with it
for a while it's very much like a
meditation is very much like a it's
called cognitive behavioral therapy is
just a form of CBT but I didn't really
do it intentionally that way I just came
up with these little things right for
visual yeah little visual cues and that
really helped I mean sometimes right
after Paul it was murdered I would be in
that bed 30 times a day trying to sweep
out those thoughts whatever it takes
whatever it took this just went for
sweeper yeah yeah the swiffer sugar and
I had to lock the bedroom door and all
these because I thought people were
coming in to murder my knives because
the way she was murdered yeah I mean I
kept reliving that whole thing what she
must have felt was she must've good I
just couldn't sleep at night well no so
I went and then another thing i did was
i got an egg timer and this came from my
psychiatrist he said why don't you try
what they call it the kitchen timer
technique I got an egg timer and he said
decide how many minutes you want to feel
bad for any time you want to feel bad
and then just feel it in the min ago and
then let it go when the time runs out it
runs out so I got one of these little
hourglass ones and turns up for five
minutes and I would send it for five
minutes at a time and I would just cry
why it's green punch a pillow do
whatever I had to do huh and then when
the timer went off click well you gotta
get out and eventually again it's over
nice and now I still get them I mean I
won't say everything is good but now i
get them maybe once or twice a month you
know yeah nice which is better than 30
times a day yeah better yeah and I don't
cry on 24 hours yeah long day so those
are some of the techniques that I used
and of course there's there's a lot more
in the formal thing and then getting
back to work taking that first step
beginning with it yes getting out the
door the first time one step leads to
the next to the next right absolutely so
Victor Franko had this system any you
call it look us here blows air okay
Sarah think it's quite simply means
healing through meaning okay well look
we want to talk about it some more but
we're gonna go to break and let's talk
about what you've learned about
logotherapy and then also you did
another movie and had learned some other
ways to deal with things so let's talk
about both of those and
can kind of will let you be the expert
and chair share their ways of well I'm
not a professional like a therapist but
I'm an armchair looketh that's okay take
that here we got some arm chairs for you
so we'll be back with Mary Somalia in
just a minute we want to hear from our
wonderful sponsors and and then we'll be
back to talk some more about how to get
over some challenges in your life and
how do then bring all those positive
things in your life to accomplish more
welcome back we're learning all kinds of
cool stuff about how to get out of
challenges because we all want to get
out of challenges right well Mary you
were talked about healing through
meaning which is so part of logotherapy
tell me a little bit more about that
well dr. Victor Franko was first of all
a physician in healer and a psychiatrist
and a great philosopher and he grew up
in Vienna Austria we're thinking was in
the 30s 1930s and 40s and 50s the way of
the land and he followed he's he's off
his theory come logotherapy is often
called the third school of Viennese
psychotherapy the first being Freud
everybody's heard of the Freud theories
right and dr. Freud was all about
finding his theories were all about
finding meaning through pleasure in your
life more sex more pleasure more goods
and franco and adler both came along and
said we don't agree with that so dr.
Alfred Adler was the second school of
Viennese psychotherapy and he he thought
that it was all about power that you
could you could feel more find more
meaning if you were a powerful person if
you're powerful in your career and so
Franco came along and said no you're
both wrong and of course I'm simplifying
it a great deal but he said of what what
is missing what man must do is find
meaning in his life so logotherapy our
winery by logo it is not the cup kind of
logos logos is a Greek word which means
simplistically feeling and and so is
healing through meaning so dr. Franco
described his school of logotherapy as a
therapeutic tool to be used by
psychiatrist and psychotherapist in
helping people find meaning in their
lives I like that one much better than
the Freud or the other is really about
sex and power will throw you off I think
every single side yeah that's right
keep trying to prove it over and over
again you know right now but he gave us
very three very specific ways of finding
meaning in our lives by using techniques
that he uncovered okay um the first
group is called the creative values okay
um where you can and he articulated this
much better than I because I'm not a
trained professional in this field I'm
just certain I only pretending you are
and I am yeah cuz I thought it was you
are about it so yes expert can now call
myself an armchair leggett their visit
oh good but but the professionals use
terms like creative values experiential
values and attitudinal Vegas and i'll
talk about all three for just a little
bit because you can find meaning in one
or the other you oftentimes will find
different sets of meetings moment to
moment year to year dragon yeah it all
changes but it's important to know that
you can always find me regardless of the
circumstances in your life which that's
what I was telling you and the creative
value speak to things like finding a
work creating a job creating a business
writing a book making a movie doing
something creative Oh being a painter
being an artist accomplishing something
accomplishing some work-related go and
the experiential values would be about
encountering another person finding
somebody to love there's all kinds of
experiences that we can have in our
lives that would bring us meaning right
and then there the attitudinal values
and that's what came into play for me
the most because suffering there is
meaning and suffering you don't have to
suffer to find meaning right but in that
in that suffering you can choose your
attitude and that's part of the
attitudinal values and what you've made
that choice then you have you can start
to uncover a meeting in your life I came
so far down and I always say that my
solid foundation was built on rock
bottom right yeah yeah um pretty solid
yeah that's all what do you want wrong
doesn't get any more solid Isaiah
foundational yeah I didn't
I mean a lot of people say when you're
so happy all the time you probably never
had a bad day in your life I said well
you might be surprised right yeah
kidding I didn't land on this
mountaintop step into my lava let me
tell you but actually they say you never
land on a mountaintop right oh I don't
know yeah oh yeah I read that the other
day ok clear Edison and yeah it is a
good one yeah yeah but anyway so I found
through my suffering that I could choose
the attitude I wanted once I I realized
and and that came from rereading again
man's search for me because I had sort
of forgotten about it and then of course
when I met Alex that we start to do the
movie the whole thing turned into a
creative value and I met him and we
became great friends and it was an
experience that all those three came
together for me for the perfect I'm so
what yeah yes damn storm American
experiment experiential various my dear
yeah with you out there too yeah acting
with us exactly mm-hmm we grow from that
there's meaning in what we're talking
about absolutely so so I could rap you
know as a as a person who loves it
thrives on education and research those
were three things I could really wrap my
head around right and so it saved my
life hmm it saved my life I was suicide
I set in there's chair and thought to
myself well you know you're medically
trained you can take some drugs out of
cabinet you can hook yourself up to an
IV you can give yourself a little
pitiful give yourself a little peg when
you get out of this mess hmm why then I
thought okay yeah no no you know I want
to pull a michael jackson yeah but i
mean i had recurrent thoughts of suicide
all the time all the time we went
through a lot up until i got had the
psychotic break right after that i have
not had him that break was a savior for
you it was God's anesthesia yeah yeah
okay Tennessee that's amazing so anybody
that's out there experiencing a
difficult time right now what do you
think that first few steps are that they
would take two that's right ago I think
the first thing is to try and get rid of
your automatic negative thoughts rewrite
your script that's
for life in your head you can you can do
that from your bid you can do it from
your living room you can use the sweep
I'll loan it G is free I can buy mine
anytime ok and if you order now free
shipping um and then fine you know fine
a lot of times during hard times we
alienate our best friends true oh good
point and because they want to fix your
mind but your mind is what sick it can't
be fixed for the low ones we love or the
ones we love we tend to push away those
were closest to very true so I say once
you have identified a way that you could
see some light at the end of the tunnel
that you can see your way back then
start to bring in all your support group
again right okay so you gonna kill
yourself once you can't go your semi
first ring because happiness dr. Franco
wrote this and it's so true you can't
you can't search for happiness happiness
must ensue brain if you can't get her
sooo it right in fact and and not only
must we do it we have the responsibility
to do it we'll talk a little bit about
responsibility later on a hook because
good based on dr. Frankel's teachings
there's a great movement of front now
called the statue of responsibility
right and so we can we can delve into
that a little bit more better you can go
into that now if you want to okay we
actually have one of our other episodes
that you might you know if you're
watching this on on you know the
archives you can actually go and watch
one with with Lisa and Gary price who
are you know the sculptor and the
executive director for the statue
responsibility so we had them on our
show before well this all started
because in 1961 dr. Franco was teaching
at Harvard and I'm sure he talked about
it before that because he talked about
on every stage he spoke on around the
world from then on and he said that what
America needs because there's so much in
those days with the Vietnam War and with
this and that there was so much struggle
to find meaning I think we still have
that problem without them the war going
yeah well we see our Wars oh that's
yeah so we still have wars within our
sales regardless and so he said that
what America needs is a statute
responsibility on the west coast of the
United States to book in the Statue of
Liberty on the east coast of the United
States because freedom without
responsibility is no freedom law that's
true that's right here yeah and we and
so a statue of responsibility foundation
was developed it but yeah it began in
the early 90s and don't quote me on this
but it started with Kevin hall Stephen
Covey another guy named Jim whose life
they may never remember and dr. Franco
and rage aim together they would Jim
poor Jim sorry sorry Jeff work Jim is
passed away anyway okay okay town
meeting yeah he found higher ground yeah
but anyway they came together and
discuss this at you know really
seriously that what would it take to the
have this monument this 300-foot
monument built on the west coast nited
states it would be like the Statue of
Liberty foundation and so they went to
Vienna they traveled to Vienna and they
met with well oh no first Kevin hall
contacted Gary league price the world
renowned sculptor right in Utah and
commissioned him to design the statute
responsibility and this is such a great
story I love this part because mrs.
Frankel also told me about it when I
visited her in Vienna gehry-designed
hands that connect yeah and they are
like this and that one reaches down and
the other one it reaches up and we could
call it connecting humanity but I think
that was an early logo but it really
shows us that you know we are all
connected and United and when they
travel to the inner to present the first
mold event to the Franco family mrs.
Franco took Gary by the hand and dragged
him into dr. Frankel's study and dr.
Franco had passed on at this point
and she said I want to show you
something Gary and Gary had no idea of
what she was going to show him and he
had dr. Franco had a favorite carving
called the suffering man and it was in a
niche in his book case I've actually
seen it at the house in Marion Gaza and
she took it down from there in the hand
it's a bust of Christ with a hand
reaching up and she said now you have
answered my husband's question he always
asked where's the hand reaching down Wow
yeah and you bring to me a monument oh
yeah that will answer this question
that's incredible i think responsibility
is a you know big responsibility yeah
it's a big responsibility good point
thank you very much but that yes not but
not only helping each other but helping
ourselves helping ourselves yeah when he
was here when Gary was here you said
that they were a left and a right hand
they say right so that responsibility
can be something of us helping someone
else with a right and left hand or
helping ourselves exactly and we're
going to go to a break in a little bit
here and when we come back let's talk a
little bit about some of the you took a
lot of responsibility in your own life
in trying to get over all these
challenges that you've been through and
those I'm sure have helped to inspire
you and and strengthen you and you've
used utilize those things like yeah I'm
young into it right I mean this is only
six years I've been to this sure yeah
but you're but you're having success
with it you're producing movies all
those kind of things so we want to talk
a bit more about that you know exciting
things that you're doing with the film's
what some of your future plans are that
you're wanting to do okay and it and
talk about the future of responsibility
in your life right and the future of
what you want to give back to the world
in your life and maybe a little bit more
about those little decade things you
know where you're going to move on to
something every deck
they think that's incredible okay so
when we come back after these short
messages we're going to talk more with
Mary symbaloo cut and learn what you can
do it I can do to be more responsible in
our lives
I don't know about you but I am learning
some great stuff here today yeah a lot
of great stuff but we haven't learned
yet Mary is what do you do every day
your producer aren't you I'm a producer
and that's usually as i was telling
dennis that you to the first question
anybody asked me what does it producer
actually do yeah i'm curious chris is
something something well well here's
what we do in reality it sounds
glamorous but what we actually do is we
beg for money we cry about money when
you go she ate money we whined about
money we fight about money and when it
all works out you get money we get money
whoo that's the best part at least it's
not all about money at least it's not
all about money and if you know anything
about my life you'll know that the last
thing the world I care anything about is
what money yeah so I've landed into this
very strange world but that's
unfortunately what the job of producer
it does because it takes a lot of money
to make a film a lot and you have to
once you go out and you get the money
from your investors who trust you with
their money right then you have to
actually do what you said you were going
to do one of the first things I learned
when I started taking my film classes on
producing and in Hollywood is that my
teacher told me there are two kinds of
people in Hollywood you got to decide
right now today which one you're going
to be there the people who use everyone
until they get what they want and
they're the people who use everyone so
that you all get what you want I like
this one hello okay yeah yeah so and
there's really true and it's throughout
the spectrum whether it's the
cinematographers whether it's the
directors whether it's the composer's
the down to the key grips everybody's in
the same two smears right so the hardest
job I find as a producer is to figure
out the right people to be on the right
team at the right time in the right
place that's how we do right money
that's
alright sound guy and ride with editors
yeah so I just the way I approach it is
I decided when I was going to become a
producer and I had already sold my first
job before I became one I jumped off the
cliff and then I got always learning how
to do it I took every course I could
find and I found some great mentors
Suzanne Lyons is a past president of
Women in Film international and a master
talent teacher has been my mentor since
I came into this business in 2010 and
she's amazing she is a great teacher and
a great friend and she gives you all the
tools that you need to be successful if
you're willing to put in the work right
and there are others and of Simmons from
the Hollywood Film Institute I took his
courses have taken them several times
and have all his tapes so I took a
variety of different courses that took
writers course is not because I want to
become a writer to something because I
need to know how to hire writers write
and I think that's important if you're
building any business you need guys to
understand every aspect of the business
before you can actually produce anything
to get blindsided you get blindsided and
you also get talked into a lot of stuff
that will cost your company money oh
yeah if you fire the wrong writer the
right writer write yeah you can get that
stuff so I can get out i'll tell you a
little funny story about the hollywood
film is didn't everybody who's been
there knows this story so it's not off
school you took your train in Hollywood
I took my training in Hollywood running
back and forth up and down the freeways
three four five days a week whatever it
took I'm still taking classes i mean i
never i will feel like i'm a real
producer even though I a more narrow
okay but just so much to learn I mean
when you come into this in your sixth
decade and we'll talk about that I'm
going to be 65 this year and i started
this film career in this in my 60s wow
so that's kind of crazy me most people
come in in their 20s and 30s and 40s but
not me know i always everything hard way
okay that's all right
and I took this writer's course and I
gotta tell you this funny story so the
teacher who's this colorful guy named of
Simmons he stands if he says okay you
people who are in its class today you
want to learn how to write a movie
script I know that's what you all want
to hear about I'm supposed to teach you
producing but you don't give a damn's
been producing all you want to do is run
and run a script so I'm going to tell
you how to do here's how you do it you
have a beginning you have an end you
have 40 s and 50 s 50 gaseous or oh
shoots or whatever and one oh my
goodness that's your script did you put
those together 33 beat points you're
done I can do that well you know what
our own work assignment that right I'm
American time at that night was to take
five movies uh-huh dissected and see if
he wasn't right music he has been
teaching in Hollywood for 32 years and
he's taught over 5,000 producers
according to him and this is exactly
what happens in everything now i can't
go to a meeting a film without saying
talents or somebody well where's the oh
my god this is not a good movie that
you've even do famously oh my god that
is what uh somebody got stressful but
yeah the movies that you've produced
right yeah tell us one of them movies uh
Victor and I which is about dr. Franco's
life it's a personal story of his life
is called Victor and I and that's an
interesting story Alex chose the name
and I because he was interviewing all
those people closest to duck named
Franco they still alive and it's not the
eye of you and I it's the eye of the
beholder I like that talking about dr.
Frankel's worm and so it's it's Victor
and I um what's the website is a victory
ik t 0 are in I movie com ok Victor and
I movie com our second film is about dr.
Milton Erickson and that is called
wizard of the desert and it was copy
wizard because no one really understands
dr. Erickson's work
he was a genius of the 20th century also
and a Great backstory on him he grew up
in a silver mining community in a ghost
camp what's now a ghost town called orem
Nevada 7,500 feet their house the back
of it backed up to a mountain that it
was dirt Wow yeah I mean that's how
rugged it wasn't there that's a man and
his father worked for a silver mining
company that later went out of business
but then they came down the mountain top
of dr. dr. Erikson had polio and even in
spite of the polio he overcame all those
challenges and taught himself how to
heal himself and he really started
developing his theory of hypnosis in
order to prove the doctors wrong because
he got so angry laying in bed one night
when he heard the doctors tell his
mother he was going to die oh my gosh
and he said no boy should at no mother
should ever have to hear that a better
boy were they to tell him he's going to
die well made unfortunately that's what
physicians do a lot of times and they
don't always think about what they're
saying so he set out to prove him wrong
good and and he did it and he he
developed his ericksonian hypnosis which
is a different brand if not that we were
kinda not the tick-tock client right
right he thought he taught himself how
to put him to himself into a trance
mostly the heel is on paying because
eight once he had gotten over the
initial polio then it came back later as
post-polio syndrome and he was in a
wheelchair and then I going to get all
this great work and they're now 132
Erickson Institute's around the world am
I gonna at the Institute which supported
the film is the Eric Milton h erickson
institute of phoenix arizona directed by
dr. jeffrey zeig and they're doing
amazing work all over the world Wow
what's in your future I mean that well
we did a minutes left here and we want
to talk about your next 65 years oh wow
I by design all my life I've studied
something different every decade which I
I love that that's really in my sixth
decade I fell into this one x identity
right I was planning to study law in
this decade okay I didn't work out we
had a little not a hurry up of frankel
slip I had a little slip yeah I had a
little existential crisis say yes when I
lost my whole family so that side
tracked me well producing sounds more
fun than law anyways it does like one of
my um my oldest clients in my other
businesses the American Academy of
psychiatry and the law and I've been
interested in criminal losses i just
started doing there yeah so is that
something that's something in my 80s i'm
gonna do okay 80 so the database i'm
hoping to study creative writing in
theology love it combined nice because i
like to write but i don't really
understand the structure of writing so I
want to study that formerly yeah and I'm
going to say creative writing so I tell
Alex Alex was to make my partner's Alex
vesely is the director he wants to make
the world's biggest sci-fi film and I
want to see him get his Oscar believe me
yeah I'm mentoring him and that's my
goal is for him to get his first Oscar
right before I leave so we've only got
five more years I'm gonna guide this
year right so we got to get at it right
on to greener pastures I'm moving on to
well he'll be he'll be all set and set
the world on fire he's a very smart
young man that's great i love that yeah
so you know of all the things we've
talked about you know we've just got a
few minutes before we finish up the show
what would you say is that one golden
nugget that one bit of information for
somebody that well if I had my life has
been built around my mantra which is if
you live your life from the inside out
and not from the outside in most of your
days will be wonderful i love that and
you don't need stuff coming at you in
this consumer culture you don't need
cars you don't need houses you don't
need stuff right what you need is to
develop your heart and to find people to
give it to
so if you find things that you can work
in your passion you can work from your
heart you can speak from your heart you
can love from your heart you can give to
your heart you can find people to help
you know but I serve I'm in this world
to serve not to take right Wow Ted to
bin not to break and to love not to hate
hello Matt and I know that and I've
always known that intuitively wow so
that's what I would say try to develop
your inside person mm-hmm and figure
ways to get it out to the world so they
can that they can learn more about your
films at learn more about films at
victor in iMovie com or wizard of the
desert movie com okay and then in five
years they'll be going to your your son
side right on website or something we
love having you on the show thank you so
thanks for coming guys have been great
really appreciate it and we appreciate
you sharing your real self too it wasn't
a show where we had to fabricate a bunch
of stuff I wish I yeah yeah we'll have
to do one of those shows where yeah yeah
we'll make up a bunch of stuff so but in
the meantime it's thank you for sharing
your heart with us yeah absolutely some
of those spots that we talked about
today or pretty gripping pretty I'm
pretty Ross yes and so you know if
you're you're out there and you're
dealing with some of those real heavy
challenges we know that people are
getting killed on airplanes and Diana
cancer and everything else and they may
be good friends of yours or even family
bring out the sweeper yes you can get
the sweeper I'll get the sweeper so so
thanks again we loved having you don't
really do and I want to remind all of
you that if you're wanting to be able to
get through challenges and get through
the opportunities that you see in front
of you get through the door and make
things happen then if you're thinking
about being successful remember the
thing that we tell you every week and
that is
thinking about being successful and
start doing something about it I want to
know by next week that you've done at
least one more thing that's gotten you
closer to your goal see you next week